today's video is sponsored by
surfshark hi um i have a pretty simple
one
i just feel like men don't get when
women
put a lot of effort into their
appearance like we get our nails done we
get our hair
done we pay a lot for an outfit and all
that
and then they don't want to like pay for
dates or like pay for anything and they
just expect us to look good all the time
i don't pay for outfits
i don't pay for shoes i don't pay to go
to the barber every now and then
i don't pay for cologne i don't pay what
makes you think i don't pay
you don't even value what's in front of
you lady me smell good you think i don't
have like
shower body body wash in my house
all sorts of different scent the shape
the dress shape up the dreads you think
these just come like that
what about your outfit like what you
think you think my fit
this you think this this is free my
[ __ ]
huh you think these are free my [ __ ]
look at that flick of that wrist look at
the flick of that wrist
uh-huh look how flicky that wrist the
hell is this you think all this is for
free
you did my fit my fence for free
it's just laying there in my what you
think i don't pay for [ __ ] you do you
need
i should show up butt naked is that what
it is i just show up in my joggers what
happened and you show
if i don't show it to if the gray
joggers what happened you know if it's
gray joggers you're gonna be like yeah
okay but
if it's a date date like you're talking
like you put effort
but because i don't put makeup on i
don't put effort on
girl the [ __ ]
you think oh all this freshness it's the
[ __ ] you think this is
why did you turn to mary j blige what's
that spicy chicken
spicy chicken
you think men should notice your nails
they do
although you think men should notice
your nails your pedicure
your good looks and then like damn this
girl she put in work
and that's why i should pay well yeah
because we put in so much financial
effort into our appearance
so what if a dude comes in and he's
extra buff wears the nicest armani suit
perfume on point hair gelled up looking
mint as hell
putting all the hours in the gym got the
best physique looking like tyrese
all right when he was still doing r b
okay are you paying for the day
i'm never paying for the date the [ __ ]
i'd be here with your phone
[Laughter]
give me your phone let me show your
phone give me a phone
we have to make it equal let's make it
fair yeah is this your [ __ ] phone
give me your real folks you think i'm
stupid give me your real phone
no no yeah you take it give me the real
phone yeah we throwing this one here
let's go
you thought i could do that too it's
okay all right
yeah i know i made it laying on the bed
first just so just to suck
out of compassion because i was nervous
you
it's out of respect though i actually
want an iphone so i can go on instagram
[Laughter]
she said no she said no i'm not paying
for never i'm never paying nothing to do
with the price that's what i said
there's nothing to do with the price
[ __ ] out of here you just don't want to
pay
[ __ ] out of here take all your nice [ __ ]
your clothes your
your hair your nails your fit your shoes
your purse get the [ __ ] out of here it
ain't got nothing to do with that
ain't got nothing to do with the price
you just don't want to pay i don't want
i showed up i shut up
i'm here i showed up so you should pay
that's what the [ __ ] man i shut up
again
that's a good character it's good that's
good but that's what it is though
yeah if i was at the olympics i raised a
10.
i shut up i [ __ ] their own routine but
ash salute to the judges fell in
salute i showed up
today's video is sponsored by surf shark
vpn
so vpn is basically an application or
web extension
that you could use on your web browser
or on your internet to mask
your ip address basically hiding your
location from whatever website you're
interacting with
now you might think why would i want to
hide where i'm at it doesn't matter well
unfortunately there are places that
block you based off of
your ip address and so if you're trying
to view
online content on let's download certain
things based off where you live
those things could be restricted now i
like watching tv shows
feel me sometimes they're foreign feel
me and
when that happens basically i use a vpn
to be able to bypass that so i can watch
what i want to watch because i feel like
the internet's at its best
when everything's accessible if you use
promo code abba and preach
you get 83 off plus three months free
so take advantage of the deal watch what
you want to watch and don't be
restricted by anyone's barriers
you deserve to go wherever you'd like to
go
let me ask you something if you just had
simple clean nails simple clean
you know feet okay if you had minimal
makeup
and you had like a decent outfit do you
think men would be like
i'm not going on a date with this girl
no but i'm talking about me
but i want to ask her do you think those
men would not go on a date with you
no they would still go on a date but
we were already in just because you came
on with extra add-ons that i didn't ask
for
did men ask you to do a pedicure i have
men
say that they appreciate when women do
pedicures and happiness i appreciate a
lot of things i think it's great when
you wanted to wear a nice alpha
did men ask for that no do we require it
some men say they prefer it hey
i prefer a lot of things i go to work
some days and i prefer having like a
a luxury chair when i'm doing my office
work
but if you said hey you want that office
chair it's going to cost you more money
i'd be like put it back let's give me
the regular chair
i didn't ask for it if you give it to me
maybe
thank you but i'm not going to pay more
i don't understand why ladies put on
this extra stuff that we never
asked for we never uh tell me one girl
or one guy who messaged you and said
hey make sure your nails done
your your your nails your [ __ ] feet
done
all right put on extra makeup where the
nice
when does a man ever ask you okay let me
let me
not answer your question and go back to
the other [ __ ] i was talking about i'll
let you know this i've learned
from that mistake i don't let them run
away [ __ ] i asked you a question
no no answer my question answer that
question
let's see what her answer is when does a
man ask you that
i've had a man say that he likes me
better when i'm dressed up and i have my
nails done all that well that's not what
i asked you it's not what i asked you
when does a man ask you to do that or
made it a requirement
never so there you go first boss
he's my thing you look good
congratulations
you look fresh congratulations
you expect me to play you played
yourself
okay i didn't ask for all that if i show
up to a date
and i got a ten thousand dollar armani
suit am i expecting you to pay because i
put in all this effort i put in all this
financial burden of course not
her logic nonsense she doesn't believe
in what she's saying
she's just trying to find a way to
justify her desire of gender roles
saying all this [ __ ] about i put in
all this effort blah blah blah
stop you lying and it's okay
i know you lying right because you're
doing this whole like you know thing
where you dance around
why you wanna just say i'm a woman this
is what i deserve
but all this stuff about you dressing up
boo-boo last i checked
don't women dress up for themselves not
that [ __ ]
don't do them make them do the makeup
for themselves for you boo-boo don't
they do the pedicure for themselves
lingerie two baboon right don't they go
to work and make sure everyone else gets
to see it damn shoes is for you too but
did they them [ __ ] pay to see that
no but i gotta pay to see that don't
bring that up don't
no careful careful because
you said that was all for you keep the
same energy boo-boo
it was for you yep it's still for you
always
but i have male friends who say they
prefer me
like i was saying they prefer me with my
nails done my makeup done just looking
feminine and all that
and they're like don't go back to how
you were before and they're talking
about how they want to date me and stuff
but then they're not willing to pay for
dates and all this other stuff and it's
like this costs money
you know you have a whole job for that
if i'm paying you to look good and come
out there's a there's a word for that
that's a
that's an escort service i ain't mad at
it
it's okay goo go go on boo
out there live your life you want to be
that live your life
but call yourself that that's that
escort mentality
that trophy wife thing if i'm pain
shut the [ __ ] up but my whole point is
we didn't make that a requirement you
know what i'm saying that's not a
requirement from us
if you go to your job okay and you put
on your best makeup your best snails
your people are working like damn you
look good today all right you came in
nice and dressed
extra extra we appreciate that right
does that mean that they're going to
give you a raise because you put on your
hair your makeup and all that perfectly
no why because they didn't ask for that
they still hired you for the job even
though you came in looking
great so at the end of the day
ladies i support y'all look as good as
you
okay but then don't look at us and be
like if you appreciate a lot of women
always talk about like subscribing to
these gender roles but you're not
a lot of y'all are not traditional women
which is perfectly fine
but i just find it crazy how y'all want
to pick and choose when you want to do
these whole traditional things
it's like that era is gone it's been
dead y'all are succeeding y'all killing
it y'all living your best lives
pay up all this talk about living
get that apron get back in that kitchen
start cooking home meals
why are y'all talking about oh i like
true traditional gender roles y'all
can't cook
y'all can't clean you can't cook cook
all right if i go through your
crib your bathroom chernobyl let's be
honest
so there's all this talk about like
subscribing to these roles that men
should pay
but at the same time ladies y'all move
into the modern age so
either either you fully subscribe to the
past and you bout it about it
but i'll be trying to pick and choose
all the time the parts that you like
because the parts that you don't
y'all don't want to do and it happens to
be the parts that men like in
traditional women
so that's my thing that's pretty much my
thoughts what do you got
i shut up man you did it
you threw my phone
you threw my phone too we quit come down
yeah i was
to no you wasn't anyways
my phone protectors don't give [ __ ]
[Music]
shut up
be